ils étaient des dizaines de milliers
vendredi dernier à marcher pour la
défense de l'environnement et il voulait
des gestes concrets
la réaction est donc arrivé nous
consacrons des moyens importants à la
lutte
la lutte contre les changements
climatiques greenwashing avec des bots
petit logo comme ceux ici peu comme sur
les boîtes de céréales contient plus de
fibres c'est de la graine
et pendant que les étudiants du
secondaire manifester une nouvelle fois
ce vendredi ceux de l'université
rencontrer le ministre de
l'environnement pendant toute la nuit on
a eu une équipe d'étudiants aux
étudiants qui se sont affairés à
détailler ce budget qui est vide au
niveau de l'environnement
mais en arrière-plan beaucoup
d'agitation un engagement
[Musique]
on s'était promis une heure on attend
près de deux heures un simple on s'est
partagé des propositions un des
participants a tenté de résumer les
paroles entendues autour de la table la
collection amériquébec mais j'ai dit que
c'était possiblement dans les plans de
faire un plan qui forcerait à l'atteinte
de cible seulement des paroles selon
dominic champagne qui a lui aussi
interpellé le ministre ce que le message
est bien passé on avait une belle
communication sont les discos son bolide
dialogues sont ouverts mais si l'argent
parcimonie tox hier on n'a pas grand
chose à se mettre sous la dent dans le
budget clairement le gouvernement ne
rien annoncer le les mains vides encore
une fois ça fait presque six mois qu'il
est en place au lieu de financer la
solution est bien une finance le
problème en faisant en voulant faire
l'expansion du système autoroutier
les étudiants eux sont déterminés à
maintenir la pression sur le google
c'est dommage quand même car cet âge là
c'est notre tour de prendre les
responsabilités
je pense que là on a la preuve qu'on est
prêt à les prendre on manifeste on veut
continuer à manifester tant et aussi
longtemps que nos revendications ne pas
être respecté rendez vous vendredi
prochain pour une nouvelle mobilisation
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal